[Music]
my next guest is a comedian and the host
of totally biased with W kamau Bell on
FX here's a segment on police harassment
take a look I'm tired of being searched
like I want to be searched by ladies if
it was ladies cops I wouldn't mind it I
searched me every day do you dress like
this for your job or so you don't get
stopped and frisked
what if every time they stopped you they
gave you a soda and they cover like pop
and frisk popping first I'll be tight
does that make it better
Oh popping laughs oh look at you look at
you man
every time they stopped you and uh to
frisk you every sixth time you got a
free Subway sandwich would that make it
better you know no okay
or if you're really good they give your
spanking afterwards put that part out no
we won't
don't edit that part out first thing I
want you're you're on a bit of a mission
which is to break down racial
stereotypes yes uh on your show do you
feel like you are getting through to
your audience do you feel like you're
having an effect well the show the FX
show totally biased grew out of my solo
show is called the W kamau Bell curve
ending racism in about an hour
right which we did every time right yes
it just takes one hour and racism except
when people leave they become more races
immediately so that's if we could lock
them in the room but yeah so it grew out
of that show but and I would do the show
a lot and people would like it and dig
it I thought oh I'm actually making a
difference and after one show one time a
woman came with you after the show white
woman is like this show is great I loved
it I just had to tell you one thing you
look like the monkey from the Rugrats
you're kidding no and I was like you had
to tell me you had think you could
probably never have told me that
so that's one of the rules we're going
to put in the show don't tell Blackie
like monkeys yeah I thought we had to
start ending racism with that early
point yeah well okay what is the racial
makeup of your audience in the beginning
would you say well at first we started
the show was all it was cuz theater it's
mostly white people and it sort of felt
like court testimony it sounds like I
think I need to get some brown people in
here so we started an offer where if you
bring a friend of a different race you
get into for one interesting yes out of
that workout was great not even Martin
Luther King jr. did that I have to say
that so you you like to go out of your
way to perform in very white cities is
that true yeah like you know you got to
go to where you needed you know it's
like a jokes Without Borders you know
that kind of banks right so yeah I went
to Madison Wisconsin which is a Madison
with yes there yes oh yes a very white
tease you can tell by that yellow that's
not a black person pretty sure about
that uh yeah so into Madison Wisconsin I
did the show and actually went to a
rally called the fighting Bob fest which
is a very political
lefty rally and a lot of great speakers
were there Tom Hartman Cornel West a lot
of people after the after the rally
people come to you say thank you for
coming I was like that's weird I didn't
perform everybody thanked me for coming
like thank you the find this guy's like
it's so important you're here I was like
oh man these people think I'm Cornel
West we actually have a split screen of
you and Cornel West
I was yes yeah yes anyway I'm really
insulting to both of us yeah exactly
yeah now you you majored in school you
majored in political science no no no
people always think that I actually
majored in East Asian Studies in college
Oh cuz I like Bruce Lee a lot wait a
minute was that really the reason that
you majored in East Asian stuff yeah I
went to college and I just like I like
Bruce Lee a lot what major is close to
liking Bruce Lee a lots ass-kicking
exactly yeah they didn't have that at
the University of Pennsylvania so I
picked East Asian Studies and I found
out about a year and I have like yeah
this isn't getting me closer to Bruce
Lee but I did take a year and half of
Chinese and I I learned everything I
need to know you know okay what did you
learn whooping how Nina whoa hoon Gao
Malby which basically means I'm fine how
are you I'm fine I'm very tall pencil